I finally protest the st. Louis Park
Minnesota City Council now reconsidering
a decision to actually do away with the
Pledge of Allegiance before meetings now
the council claimed it was creating a
more welcoming environment to serve a
diverse community by getting rid of the
pledge I think the one thing we could
agree on that we live in the greatest
country God gave man but apparently not
we sent our own Lawrence Jones the st.
Louis Park to ask people there what they
thought that council take a look in st.
Louis Park the get rid of the Pledge of
Allegiance before the City Council
meeting right how do you feel about that
I pretty horrible because isn't it a
government only part of a government
that we should be doing that should be
up to the city and I think people have a
right to you know express their opinions
about it I don't have to say the pledge
allegiance I want respect being taught
to people whether they're saying words
it's more action the st. Louis Park City
Council's say that the please' Legion
isn't diverse enough do you agree with
the and they know where we fall fuzz I
really think it is I think that we can
all identify as Americans and we all
really have the same true values and and
at the heart of that is democracy they
say is not reflective of the values of
the community it's not diverse enough I
may be old school but I'm not sure I
agree with that my sons in the Cub
Scouts they still do it my husband's in
the military we stand for the flag we
can't you're American you should be
doing the pledge allegiance I'll try to
understand creating a more welcoming
environment to serve a diverse community
it's the greatest country God gave man
Lawrence Lawrence Jones by the way Fox
News contributor is more frequent flyer
miles than anybody else at the network
also Texas congressman Dan Crenshaw but
seriously you know this this should be
one thing that you would think we all
agree on but it's not the case you know
there was always there always has been
the blame America first crowd now
there's a this hate America contingency
out there Loren said I'm trying to
understand
why what country would they prefer we
model yes sir we're sitting right here
right outside of st. Louis city parks
City Hall right behind us we're Patriots
descended there and said look it only
takes 15 seconds so say the Pledge of
Allegiance now obviously this is a
liberal town and so you have mister
action some of the Liberals said look we
want to hear the pleasure believes that
some of them says that it is
discriminatory towards some citizens in
this country the bottom line is this
charm we have issues in America but at
the end of the day we should be united
on the causes of them there it's the
Constitution that gives us so much
protections look Sean this starts on the
college campuses though there's this
growing movement of professors and
academics that are teaching these young
people in teaching the public at large
to hey they don't even teach them
everything here's the land of the free
and look at hidden teacher look and if
such a slanted view look at the reaction
the president in his fourth of July
honoring of the military with a great
history of thought and it's just that's
the military that beat back communism
fascism Imperial Japan and Nazism and
I'm thinking wow have we really
forgotten that this country is as great
as my friend Barry Farber says there's
never been a country in the history of
man that has accumulated more power and
abused it less than the United States
we're not perfect and I would add
there's never been a country that's
accumulated more power and used it to
advance the human condition more than
this one we can't say a pledge yeah no
that's exactly right and there's just
there's this disturbing trend that we
keep on saying seeing we have to wonder
where we're at right now where we can't
even see the Pledge of Allegiance and
what is it about the bunch of allegiance
that infuriates people so much you know
liberty and justice for all for all not
for some people but for all and how that
is not inclusive and diverse is beyond
me and we have to get to this point
where we start to appreciate who we are
as Americans and what brings us together
it's not necessarily geographic area
it's not necessarily skin color or
religion or ethnicity it is the red
white and blue and there are certain
things that connect us some of those
things are the pledge of
and about national anthem and the
American flag and we have to recognize
that those traditions and and symbols
and that bond is where ik where are
these people going to go where were they
gonna go gonna be in America if you
can't get freedom here where's the next
country there's gonna fight and defend
that's right all the other nations as
well thank you both